a warm welcome back to CBS mornings we
all know the holiday travel season is
here but there is one hidden danger you
may not be thinking about as you head
out of town and that's carbon monoxide
you'll want to listen up to this three
Americans died recently in Mexico City
and there are now renewed calls for
tighter regulations to keep Travelers
safe our Tanya Rivero has this story
my son called me and he said Candace is
no longer with us and I just
I lost it Candace Florence Jordan
Marshall and Cortez Hall had traveled to
Mexico City for Day of the Dead
festivities but the three friends were
found unresponsive in their Airbnb
rental authorities say from an apparent
carbon monoxide poisoning it was a
heartbreaking situation one death under
abuse one death too many Airbnb CEO
Brian chesky addressed the tragedy last
week on CBS mornings we will send free
coo detectors to anyone on Airbnb that
needs one we've already sent 200 000 to
our community and I've told our team
we're going to get even more aggressive
to make sure everyone complies carbon
monoxide is not often top of mind for
travelers no matter where they're going
or where they're staying in May
officials in the Bahamas confirmed three
American tourists died of carbon
monoxide poisoning at a resort there
were some signs of individuals
presenting to the clinic with nausea
vomiting and some symptoms carbon
monoxide is an odorless colorless toxic
gas emitted by combusting Fuel the
symptoms of Co poisoning are flu-like
headache dizziness nausea only 14 states
have CO detector regulations for hotels
if people knew the truth about not just
how many states have requirements but
how convoluted the requirements are I
think they would be very surprised at
the lack of protection we have in 2013
Chris hauschult lost both of her parents
to carbon monoxide poisoning in a North
Carolina hotel seven weeks later an
11-year-old boy died in the same room
it's just incredible and the fact that a
third person a child had to die in that
same room before anyone took action that
should be happening at all in response
hauschult founded the Jenkins Foundation
a non-profit that tracks carbon monoxide
incidents at U.S hotels we had no idea
kind of this scope of it and that it was
a danger according to the foundation's
data just over a thousand people have
been injured by carbon monoxide leaks in
hotels over the past two decades and
more than 30 have died Health experts
say this is likely a severe under count
since so many Hotel incidents go
unreported the thing that makes me most
upset is that it's preventable Dr Andrew
Moffett is a hyperbaric specialist at
Intermountain Healthcare in Salt Lake
City Utah if you had a small piece of
equipment that was installed correctly
by people who were careful then these
people wouldn't die or get extremely
sick
in a statement to CBS News the American
Hotel and Lodging Association said in
part all hotels are required to follow
applicable state and local fire
Mechanical Code and Co detection
requirements ahla encourages members to
include CO detectors in hotel rooms and
spaces with fuel fired appliances
experts say to protect yourself when you
travel bring your own battery operated
CO detector with you you can easily buy
one online guys I bought this one for
myself online after doing this story I
carry it with me everywhere this one you
can plug in and it also has batteries in
case power goes out how much is that
very good it was this one was about 30
bucks so they range in cost 30 bucks is
the low end a little cheaper but yeah it
could save your life good advice thank
you Tanya appreciate it